qui est véritablement eric de nous 56
ans chauffeur routier soupçonné par la
justice d'avoir volontairement donné la
mort à son épouse lui parle d'accident
conjugale d'une dispute qui aurait fait
chuter sa femme dans l'escalier le corps
décomposé sera retrouvé dix mois plus
tard dans une forêt près de belfort
entre temps eric de nous a sonné l
alerte et surtout bluffé tout son
entourage en jouant le mari éploré
il a agi dans un état de panique et qui
peut dire ici ce qu'il aurait fait dans
un état de panique il faut vivre un état
de panique il a voulu se débarrasser
d'une situation par conséquent il s'est
débarrassé d'un corps et ensuite il a dû
gérer
placé en garde à vue il avait fini par
avouer il faut dire que les zones
d'ombré autour de lui sont nombreuses
des traces de sang nettoyer mais détecté
par les enquêteurs au domicile
le compte bancaire de son épouse vie des
trois jours après sa disparition les
coups de fil pressant à sa maîtresse
avec qui il menait une double vie
sulfureuse
enfin il y à cette suspicion d'un
empoisonnement souvent rappelé lors des
débats l'empoisonnement qu'elle a subie
en 2012 est ce qu'on sait qu'elle a
une ablation de l'estomac suite à
l'ingestion de produits caustiques et
notamment du destop de l'eau de javel
qu'elle aurait prises à son insu me font
penser qu'effectivement on était dans
une logique depuis à peu près un peu
plus d'un an et demi
d'élimination de son épouse durant cette
première journée l'accusé est resté sans
émotions y compris lors de l'évocation
très clinique par les gendarmes des
restes du corps de son épouse retrouvé
dans une forêt eric de nous reste
impassible
énigmatique même aux yeux de la cour et
des jurés
la peine encourue pour ce type de
meurtre sur conjoint et la peine
maximale c'est à dire la perpétuité